[Musique]
sur cette séquence je vais vous montrer
la conduite à tenir face à une personne
qui a une obstruction complète des
voises aériennes tout en mangeant
j'arrive près de la victime et là la
victime a les mains à la gorge à la
bouche ouverte il y a aucun son qui
sortent Matteo tu m'entends à ce moment
là je vais laisser dans la position il
se trouve pourra régir plus rapidement
je vais le pencher en avant tout en le
soutenant pour faciliter la sortie du
corps étranger et avec le talon de la
main je vais taper entre les omoplates
vigoureusement naturellement là je mime
jusqu'à 5 fois maximum si au bout de 5
fois c'est sorti on va le rassurer et
appeler si c'est pas sorti il faut
passer à une autre technique donc tout
en laissant la victime dans la position
où je l'ai trouvé je vais mettre à sa
même hauteur derrière elle passer mes
bras sous ses bras et mon point le dos
de la main vers le ciel je vais le
positionner juste au dessus du nombril
à votre ma part dessus mes bras écartés
et là en étant contre la chaise pour
avoir un plan dur je vais tirer vers moi
et remonter ce geste là va compresser
les poumons et donc faciliter la sortie
du corps étranger par un effet piston et
donc là la deuxième pareil 5 fois 2e
fois crash voilà et tout
la victime tous elle est sortie
d'affaires on va la rassurer ne
t'inquiète pas ce qui t'empêchait de
respirer et sorti d'accord tu risques
plus rien ça va tu respires mieux ok bon
ben voilà et pour avoir un avis médical
car seul le médecin peut faire un
diagnostic et bien je vais téléphoner et
avoir un avis pas forcément pour qui se
déplace mais pour avoir un avis médical
dans cette séquence on va aborder la
conduite à tenir à avoir face à une
personne qui est inconsciente mais qui
respire là j'arrive près de un d'un
jeune qui est sur le sol je regarde
effectivement s'il y a un saignement
important non et là je vais commencer à
vérifier s'il parle tu m'entends
sers-moi la main des yeux
et à pas de réaction la victime est donc
inconsciente il va falloir qu'on bascule
la tête en arrière pour libérer les
voies aériennes en fait la scolarité est
inconsciente elle est bien plus molle
que lorsqu'elle dort tellement vol
qu'effectivement la langue a tendance à
descendre le problématique c'est
qu'effectivement ce qui est dans son
ventre et très liquide ça peut sortir il
peut se mettre à vomir et là si il vomit
les sécrétions gastriques peuvent
descendre dans la gorge et comme ils
respirent ça va dans les poumons il va
mourir noyer dans son vomi donc il faut
le mettre sur le côté pour cela on
commence par retirer les lunettes pour
préserver le visage rassemblez les
jambes le bras qui est de notre côté on
va le mettre faire deux angles droits
vers le haut pour libérer l'articulation
faire la circulation sanguine se fasse
bien prendre la main opposée la mettre
contre son oreille ça va garder la tête
les voies aériennes libérées le temps du
retournement soulevez le genou extérieur
pour faire un bras de levier et donc
sans effort même si la victime est plus
lourde que nous en appuyant sur le genou
ça tourne tout seul ma main bloquée je
la retire en retenant son coude j'enlève
le masque je j'ouvre sa bouche pour que
les sécrétions ont gastriques sanguines
et salivaires
puissant d'aller et là je vais
stabiliser le bassin en mettant l'axe
genou hanche perpendiculaire au ventre
on va couvrir la victime avec un pull
une couverture de survie pour la
préserver donc des intempéries et
préserver sa température corporelle on
prévient les secours pour dire que la
victime est en position latérale de
sécurité et on va surveiller il faut
vérifier qu'il continue à ventiler
t'inquiète pas les secours vont arriver
les victimes qui entendent tout jusqu'à
l'hôpital donc on continue à leur parler
je vais mettre la main sur votre ventre
et là il faut qu'on puisse sentir les
mouvements du ventre pour s'assurer que
la victime respire et donc assurer la
surveillance jusqu'à l'arrivée des
secours
dans cette séquence on va voir comment
agir face à une personne adulte qui est
en arrêt cardio-ventilatoire j'arrive
près de la victime j'ai effectué la
protection elle ne saigne pas d'accord
serez-moi la main madame qui est des
yeux madame vous m'entendez il y a pas
de réponse elle est donc inconsciente
comme on l'a vu avant je bascule la tête
en arrière pour vérifier si elle respire
un ne respire pas je ne vois pas son
souffle je ne vois pas son ventre je
sens rien elle est en arrêt cardio
ventilatoire là tout de suite ce qui
prime c'est d'alerter puisque la
meilleure chance de survie elle est liée
à l'arrivée précoce et secours donc on
demande à quelqu'un un monsieur vous
pouvez aller alerter les secours et
revenir qu'à des fibrillateurs et on
commence donc le massage cardiaque si on
a un nez tout seul on met le téléphone
sur haut-parleur et on fait les deux en
même temps l'alerte et le massage là il
va falloir compresser le cœur pour faire
circuler le sang on va donc choisir
l'animal on déshabille la victime et
avec le talon de la main on va le
positionner sur le sternum à la hauteur
des de la ligne mammaire c'est là que se
trouve le cœur on met l'autre main par
dessus pour avoir plus de force on
soulève les doigts on tend les coudes on
met les épaules à perpendiculaires et là
il va falloir compresser le cœur de 5 à
6 cm pour tous et le sang jusqu'aux
organes
c'est la profondeur qui est nécessaire
pour alimenter en particulier le cerveau
1 et 2 et 3 et 4 et 5 et 6 et 7 et 8 et
9 et 10 et 11 28 29 30 le défonce un
appareil qui va faire repartir le coeur
c'est en toute sécurité alors que votre
massage les compressions thoraciques ont
pour but de faire circuler le sang mais
ne font pas repartir le coeur dans la
majorité des cas vous avez des
électrodes il vous suffit de les poser
comme indiqué sur les dessins donc là
effectivement on dit qu'il faut poser
sous la clavicule droite c'est ce que je
fais d'accord et l'autre sous la clé
sous le bras gauche
ne pas toucher le patient l'appareil
vous dit de ne pas toucher donc je
laisse analyser
analyse du rythme cardiaque en cours
choc conseiller
ne pas toucher le patient tout le monde
s'écarte attention écartez-vous là il y
a un choc électrique et on appuie sur le
bouton la victime peut bouger un petit
peu et là il y a toujours pas de
réaction donc je vais recommencer ma
réanimation et vous allez lui il y a un
métronome qui vous indique à quelle
vitesse masser
voilà et donc vous continuez les
compressions thoraciques tant que
l'appareil vous dit pas d'arrêter pour
relancer une analyse ou tant que les
secours ne sont pas arrivés
dans cette séquence on va voir de quelle
est la conduite à tenir face à une
personne qui saigne abondamment tu veux
appuyer sur ta plait ou pas rose non tu
veux pas bon écoute je vais appuyé à ta
place voilà elle peut pas appuyer parce
que ça lui fait peur c'est donc moi qui
vais appuyer et qui va allonger la
victime au sol
pour permettre au centre irriguer toutes
les parties nobles et donc préserver la
conscience donc je vais appeler ce cours
avec le téléphone en précisant qu'elle a
une hémorragie mais si maintenant j'ai
besoin de me libérer
pour pouvoir effectivement appeler les
secours et bien je vais
remplacer ma main par ma ceinture une
écharpe tiens justement elle a une
écharpe autour du cou ça tombe bien avec
ce lien large je vais remplacer l'appui
je fais avec ma main sur le tampon qui
accentue la pression sur sa main donc
effectivement je vais
positionner le lien large et entourer
tout le pansement pour comprimer le lien
large à la place de ma main
voilà en veillant effectivement que
toute la pièce soit recouverte
je vais faire un nœud
je rassure la victime t'inquiète pas tu
vois regarde ça ne saigne plus tu ne
restes plus rien et avant justement de
me libérer pour alerter les secours je
vais veiller effectivement à couvrir la
victime pour la préserver
préserver la chaleur de son corps les il
faut absolument tenir au chaud les
victimes d'hémorragiques
pour éviter l'hypothermie surveiller
effectivement que le pansement est
efficace
là on voit un petit peu la séquence par
rapport à quelqu'un qui vient de se
brûler avec une brûlure thermique chaude
la Rose a essayé de faire des crêpes
elle s'est fait mal donc première chose
qui feront fait effectivement on assure
la protection et puis on voit la brûlure
là en fonction de la couleur de la
localisation
détendu effectivement ça sera grave ou
pas là effectivement c'est grave parce
que c'est un peu foncé
c'est en même temps il y a des Clo c'est
étendu donc on va commencer tout de
suite par l'arroser doucement avec de
l'eau tiède tempérée d'accord donc 15-25
degrés d'accord on va arroser à brûlure
un petit peu au dessus si elle supporte
pas on se met au dessus pour que ça
ruisselle et que ça ne lui fasse pas mal
pendant qu'elle est arrosée je vais
téléphoner au secours pour expliquer la
situation dire qu'il y a une personne
qui s'est brûlée et que la brûlure est
étendue elle est un peu noirâtre il y a
des cloques elle est supérieure à la
moitié de la paume de la main et pour
connaître un la durée d'arrosage et leur
demander de venir une fois que j'ai
atteint la durée d'arrosage préconisée
par les secours
et bien effectivement je vais allonger
la victime au sol pour préserver la
conscience et puis pour préserver la
chaleur de son corps puisque en fait
chez les brûlés le danger si
l'hypothermie et l'infection et bien
effectivement je vais couvrir la victime
et effectivement attendre d'arriver des
secours si maintenant la brûlure est
simple et bien on va pouvoir rester 10
20 minutes sous l'eau pour pouvoir
atténuer la douleur de la victime sans
être obligé d'appeler les secours
[Musique]